New Jersey and the surrounding areas we
added a show August 11th do yourself a
favor come out and see us in Red Bank at
the Vogel theater it's going to be a
good time and you can get those tickets
it's are you garbage.com yes also you
can get uh a few remaining tickets for
June 14th Cleveland hilarities and June
15th Columbus Funny Bone get those
tickets those are going to sell out uh
you can also get t-shirts and Zippo
style lighters are you garbage.com sign
up we love you peace welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is are you
garbage hey it's that little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the group to be classy yeah
after just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host thanks really coming at you on
a beautiful day we're out back here at
hoodies in the new edition she's down at
the mall picking up a new two piece for
the summer okay talking about bringing
all the boys to the yard this year can't
wait to see that with that shamrock
shake she's got my co-host is coming at
you from right next to me he is the CEO
of Ru garbage she is international
businessman and he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love him give it
up for KJ it's Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey what up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate review subscribe on iTunes
full video of album YouTube as you know
those numbers are up cooking and then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com gang check it the [__]
out it's a party over there yeah it's a
good time don't forget about the second
greatest website of all time are you
garbage.com it's your One Stop Shop for
everything ayg get some ticks some tea
some lighters whatever you need it's
just teasing lighters but still yeah
it's a good time and they're not name
brand Zippos they're Zippo style
lighters okay everybody get off my case
Vietnam still makes a fine product how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good yeah he likes his
jean shorts tight and he likes his hair
long give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dude
what up T-Bone there we go Uncle Paulie
in the Edition dude talk about a guy
who's perfect for yelling at a
basketball game in public oh yeah this
guy lets you know how he feels I feel
like we should yell under you to get off
his lawn
put on a college shirt when you do my
weed whacking
gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests back with us again today he's
family at this point he's been one of
our best Pals in comedy uh has an
amazing podcast diversity effect has
another amazing podcast anything better
with Mr Bill Burr and has a brand new
podcast bone to pick with Mr Robert
Kelly he's on tour right now do yourself
a favor he's one of the best give it up
for Mr Paul verzi everybody
[Laughter]
take care guys it's been [__] dude I
gotta tell you something on this channel
that's for the kids there you go when I
was at a wedding and they didn't want
any uh I was at a wedding they didn't
want any they didn't want any gifts they
refused okay it was the only kid of
course there was cashing you're not
coming empty-handed dude they were like
a kid they refused and I said I go I'm
not flying yeah
it's almost getting greased somebody's
getting cash because you get there and
then oh yeah you know we just people say
that and there's a there's a bunch of
stuff sitting on the table yeah you're
running out to the ATM real quick
handed him a bank I'm up there [__]
nap Valley this Alexis with a bow on it
outside I'm like you said don't bring
anything
showed up trying to find a TD Bank out
there
somebody said that we were getting cash
out of the ATM in the hotel and they
only let you take out two bills at a
time so
is the casino
I get denied at every Casino I try to
take money out because they're all it's
like 5 30 a.m I'm 400 drinks deep down
like what are you doing
dude it's like down by the cigarette
machine on like the basement floor it's
like DeNiro Casino
right next to the break room you're
trying to pull out money in the middle
of the night
it was a Giant Mountain Dew sign next to
it
I gotta thank you guys though and I got
to thank your Amaze dude your your fans
do come out to see me dude I love that
baby
dude we I was out dude Chicago just reps
me cons like so Congo's a great comedy
dude Chicago they just come out and
people are just like man here I know
you're garbage man you gotta you gotta
go like every week
God it doesn't work that way
you know the way fans when they don't
know
yeah and it's like yeah it's kind of
nice you know how much the parking is
down here nuts yeah it's [__] 55 I
whack every time I go sit on these guys
podcasts I better be funny get my
[__] sixty dollars worth get the Easy
Pass bill at the end of the month first
he's the only guy to take a compliment
like that how about 55 bucks on these
guys they want me to come to [__] these
guys
I gotta say that's a sharp looking
eyesight you got on there my friend
[Laughter]
the thing is crisp
that thing has its own
that thing is short I think it's a Tommy
but it's a Tommy you just dropped eyes
off like my dad they're hugs the style I
knew it was a Tommy you dropped I
thought mid-sip midship dude you can't
drop eyes out in mid-sip oh look he got
hit by a sniper dude it was just pink
Mist sorry I meant the style that's what
we call them golf shirt I do look like I
just did a [__] line of blow up a
yacht Monaco
Paul's got sandals and jeans already
[Laughter]
they're with me
they're good you guys watch below deck
all right you ever see that show
oh that drama did you show me the boat
is that where you flew in is that the is
that no I didn't fly in this side okay
you gotta fly you got to be like a nice
set of Jordan sweats kind of guy it was
yeah it was uh we wore some sweats you
dressed for like game seven I feel like
you're [__] head to toe and like a
nice piece you were with the misses yeah
are we matching we were we were no we
don't do that okay we don't do the
matching we can't do the math yeah come
on you know we can't do the matching but
14. it was great to
it was great to be I was in North
Carolina so I met her I flew from
Charlotte she flew from New York we met
at LAX nice we go up to Wine Country
sure thing and then uh renting a car we
had yeah rented it would you scoop up
you know what she said why not because
we went up the coast she goes why don't
we get the jacked up Wranglers a Sahara
real I got a four-door all blacked out
no blackout wheels too
blacked out he's about to do a drive-by
out there Monster Energy drink on the
side all of a sudden Birds he's in the
Crips out there
murked out Wrangler so we drive up the
coast of this Wrangler that was pretty
good that's nice it was nice the only
thing with those is I ran it I rented
one when we were in Hawaii you're real
it's real boxy yeah it's definitely it's
got a smaller windshield it's definitely
a box but I kind of it was a little felt
good yeah a little rugged nice take the
doors off no that I couldn't tell we
could we could take the top off if we
wanted I can't do that what am I doing
I'm not gonna know how to put it back
now it's gonna start raining that's
going to have it back wrong it's going
to be leaking and [__] your doors are
backward that's a 30 charge got the
wrong doors on I got the suit on nice
nice flapping like a dog's tongue in a
breeze what are you talking about I got
sand Mist on my suit at the wedding
because I didn't know how to [__]
seal up the seats
I was having a pair of goggles oh God
damn how about that ride in folks
we had a great time how many hours is it
from out from L.A it was about three and
a half that's all right let's drive a
PCH right Pacific Coast Highway no we
did that so no so here's the thing you
can go the not great route which is an
hour less through the mountains which we
did up okay but on the way back my wife
is like you're taking a 101 the 101 down
the Pacific is what you got to do so we
did that that's nice and the coast was
really nice and you know we had to class
it up so we stopped in Santa Barbara
Pier I assume and we got some cocktails
so you know I'm not gonna go there and
not get a lobster roll sure you know you
think I'm not [__] enough so you
think I'm not getting a lobster roll on
the Santa [__] Barbara Pier you got
what they bang you out for
a lobster roll in Santa Barbara you know
what I do 30. I'll be honest with you
you want to know what I do you're not
even looking I I hand them the [__] I
hand them my AmEx the metal one I got
the metal [__] sure I don't even look
as a matter of fact when they get here
I'm just I just give it yeah but my wife
she's not cheap but she goes what if
they [__] up I want to see it she's
one of those she is she you know she
looks on here what's going on she runs a
tight ship Stacy will be like no no it's
not about cheap they [__] up they
added something dude I got the only time
I ever seen this work I was like kind of
embarrassed I was out with a group of
guys and I was younger they were older
and their wine and [__] is going around
I I wasn't part I got there later or
whatever but they were like guys like
let me see the let me see the receipt
and he pulled it out [__] flashlight
on the phone and started going over he
goes watch it this is he goes when
you're out drinking this is how you [__]
you up with bottles of wine if you get
like three bottles of this oh yeah four
balls he's like they know you're [__]
up they just ringing out dude he caught
two bottles on the thing that weren't
wow and I was like damn wow well you
look like a real [__] if everything
is correct you know what I mean I also
can't beat a guy reading it now I can't
what am I what am I gonna hold on to
everybody all right it's good I can't
I'll pay the two bottles just to save
the [__] embarrassment I'm the same
way that that's people that yeah that's
people that didn't have money growing up
that are like embarrassed by not having
like you don't want to seem cheap you
don't want to seem poor so you're like I
don't know I'll just paint double well
you know I mean you know the the my the
two things I hate more than anything in
the world is a selfish [__] and
a cheap cheap and selfish I can't handle
I can't [__] with you I had this happen
to me I don't want to know how you would
play this so we went out to uh dinner uh
for Mother's Day yeah uh my brother this
is a good one my brother had gotten the
gift so I was like listen I'll take care
of dinner [__] you know Even Stevens
all that stuff
um
get the bill
put it on the card put the tip in Buck
50 was a tip all right I leave I walk
out there was no there was no place to
put a tip or anything like that it was
just sign it okay so I was like ah maybe
you know they they don't take cash tips
or whatever I just wasn't really
thinking
I walk outside owner of the restaurant
comes running out after me he's like
hang on they the tip's already included
the tips already included you know you
don't have to whatever
150 there and you know the whole
family's there like don't worry about it
it's for you he's like you kidding me
really I'm like yeah come on look we
gotta eat that right you gotta eat that
right yeah you guys sold out the weekend
before
we moved some tickets that week yeah
shout out to Tampa yeah Tampa I love you
baby it beats Florida we love you and
Raleigh yeah yeah
give it to the kids and nobody bought
merch that weekend
yeah that was the outside Splitters
wasn't a disaster
I'll be taking that 150 back no that's a
tough one dude you can't you can't in
front of your family in front of them
could you imagine if you go oh in that
case you can't the only thing I thought
maybe is like there's nothing because it
was a 50 and 100.
I thought maybe the 50. yeah I thought
maybe the 100 an extra 50. but now I was
just like not that's that's for the
girls don't worry about it thank you no
no that's uh that's I also waited 45
minutes for the goddammit he was pissed
about it don't get me wrong that's a
Class Act of course what am I gonna do
yeah I'm glad you guys are getting money
you know what I mean guys like you thank
you guys like you guys getting money
thank you because there's nothing worse
than guys who start getting money and
they hold it even tighter that's
somebody and I have a friend as a
financial advisor who texts me weekly
being like just stop doing what you're
doing which is just spending it all
again we're completely irresponsible
yeah no that's that's that's me that's
what drives my wife crazy yeah yeah I
spend yeah I don't yeah I don't I don't
care about it and I know that's very
short-sighted
no but you want you're living you're
living dude you know you guys know what
it was like to fight sure to get and
then all of a sudden you got something
you go we were looking to buy a bar in
Philly if we're being honesty's place
all right well that's a little nuts I
mean you just got in this place you let
the paint dry what the [__] you'll back
us up on this you guys got a [__]
white claw cooler now you want to buy a
[__] bar
dude we're idiots man let's get Google
it's like 40 of bars go out of business
in the first year I'm cool yes the only
reason we really wanted to open the bar
is so we can sponsor a softball team
you know what it was a multi-layer move
you know what I learned I learned that
you got to spend on what is important to
you like for me and and Kevin knows this
uh in the brief time that we where he
was opening for me
ice it's airplanes I was on a live flat
here you know what I mean I saw I saw I
saw the Instagram stories kids in the
180.80 oh yeah I'm gonna doubt the one
but I wanna I was actually complaining
about it because it was too narrow you
know I wanted that by the way by the way
the shout out to the JetBlue mint is the
one I've never done it that's the one
that's like above everything you have
like your own other than that I heard
air Emirates is like to Dubai is like
yeah like an apartment yeah it's like
it's got like a king-sized bed yeah
there's like a masseuse or like a
massage room you gotta put the utilities
in your name I heard
wrapped around it
remember not trying to return them
things back dude I got one in the house
right now
dude Comcast used to lie I thought
Boston throw three green you're like
what the [__] crazy
you're watching 80 for Brady on a
[__] 14-hour flight
Brady
I'm sorry I gotta call will you will you
hit the Bell on the in the in the in
there no they told me to but I I didn't
yeah I did it but you wait till they
walk back again real quick so we get we
go I didn't drink I haven't drank it's I
didn't drink for 60 days okay and then I
was like I'm have a couple right sure so
we go to the Delta Sky Lounge oh it's on
our way home this is last night yeah we
go to Delta Sky Lounge where me and my
wife are having a couple glasses the
Delta Lounge out of La you find out LAX
yeah very nice yeah it's a good one all
right it's a good one it's not like
Denver you go to Denver no dude it's
like the bathroom in here dude it's
[__] and there's like two sugar
cookies and a [__] dude
I have a white cloth floating around
sugar dude there was two sugar cookies
just sugar cookies
you don't got an oatmeal raisin or a
chocolate chip I was like how about we
close this thing [__] and just save
everybody the embarrassment Consolidated
dude it was the only it was the only Sky
Lounge where they go you go we gotta
wait for two to leave I swear to God
I've been dude
it's an airport it's five dollars a cup
of the king snapped yeah did you bring
any chicks wait yeah I can't you got a
bad ratio I can't let you in the most
glamorous drink was a cranberries
[__] juice they had a machine
dude the one in [__] LaGuardia is
like a goddamn breadline it's [__]
bad dude I don't even think those people
are flying
how long I had a bus
[Laughter]
there's a handful of places that have
nice lounges and I'll do and like we
sound like [__] we just travel so
much I'll do the nice Lounge but I like
just going to a bar and getting to be
able to get a burger or a breakfast
because the food in there isn't like you
can't like order stuff yeah and that's
just so you're like fighting over
yogurts and [__] which is like that's
fine yeah I would rather just sit and
have a burger and a beer same no same
same thing and again like not trying to
act like like you said we're not trying
to act like divas here it's just when
you do our job and you get to the one
thing that you want is for me it's nice
travel and nice uh hotels that's it
that's all yeah like I don't care I'm
not like one of these it's got to be top
I don't have a rider I don't when
they're like what do you want the Green
Room I'm like dude water I'm fine
they're like oh you're so like low
maintenance I just want the the travel
you know so we get little have we get a
little not buzz but like so stop a
little bit a glass of red wine yeah a
couple glasses
then they started handing out
complimentary Margaritas that were like
purple from and like okay
so she was like this is delicious then I
had a gin drink anyway we're sitting on
this we're sitting at Delta one it's
like the 1920s with him we're sitting in
Delta one it's like 11 30 at night and
everybody my wife is everybody's
starting to you know go down oh you flew
the over now that's nice yeah yeah so
yeah relax so stations like I can't do
she's a we ate I can't do Durham just
out so it's all dark in there it's like
12 30. and the guy comes over and all I
want to do is sleep and he goes all
right so we got the meatballs and the
chicken Caesar and I go he got meatballs
where are we talking here I mean I'm
telling everybody's alcoholic they were
shot in the neck with a dart and I'm
sitting up and I go all right dude I'll
go there's three eagles yeah there's
three I got all right did I do the
meatballs and a Prosecco dude it's
[__] one o'clock in the morning I
mean when I tell you everyone looked
like they were murdered I'm sitting up
in the dark Stacy is Stacy's on the lay
flat [__] spoon in a pillow I'm
sipping a Prosecco I got a [__] can
meatball and a little [__] garlic
bread and then I laid down and had the
worst acid oh yeah dude I had a meatball
ground beef laying down
I paid for that [__] ruined my life
dude I didn't even think about the heart
if they're Margaritas red wine Prosecco
I told my wife he's making a sandwich
with the garlic bread might as well be
eating firecrackers yeah she goes how'd
you sleep like I was tossed
she's like yeah we had an Italian meal
at one in the morning two more meatball
subs Robina boys they're fried calamari
might have been a mistake but what are
you gonna do what do you want what'd you
watch on the plane no I was out that's
it that's it I ate I had a Prosecco I
ate my meatballs I laid down and I
tossed and turned for four and a half
hours with a horrible sleep so it's like
an Alka-Seltzer commercial okay let's
talk about that Ridge wallet baby
yeah I've seen your wild and it is
terrain I know you gotta get over there
and get rich talking about Reed the fine
in the wallet game Ridge wallet expands
to fold up to 12 cards a little room for
cash while remaining as Slim as possible
unlike some people I know ridgewell
actually just sent us a whole pack of
them I can't wait to break it out and
start using it and flexing baby uh with
over 30 colors and styles to choose from
including carbon fiber and forged Ember
you can shop for any dad or dad while at
Haver this Father's Day do it baby
they're fantastic like he said they're
changing the game it fits everything you
need you leave it out you got your ID
your credit cards your your Costco card
your same club's car whatever you need
any reward your Wawa rewards card if you
got I got my Costco card I know you do
big guy throw my picture on the back uh
while you're at it give ridge's key case
a try the key case securely holds up to
six keys and prevent your keys from
jingling uh want to secure cash and keys
get up to 30 off when you buy Ridge
wallet and key case together
here's the turkey baby find the best
Father's Day gift using our Link in the
description ridge.com garbage and right
now you can save up to 40 percent
through June 15th baby act now that's
ridge.com garbage save up to 40 through
June 15th do it okay let's talk about
that bespoke boost Baby Oh you mean the
Box are awesome yeah I know me and you
like waiting for that box Austin to show
up get a cool buck knife cool guy [__]
baby cool guy stuff you got outdoor
stuff you got grooming stuff you got
camping stuff you got stuff for the home
bar it's a win-win baby cause you know
what
small business Brands they take care of
you they know what they're doing they
got cool guy [__] for cool guys like me
that's what that's what we're doing I
used it today they sent me a new green
knife with a little sharp it's perfect
size I use it to open up all my packages
because I'm not a real man it's all
right I got nothing to use it for I live
in a goddamn apartment but I open up my
boxes I keep mine next to the bed I
don't even think about it cut your
toenails with uh to get started just
take the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will all will help their team
pick the right box for you sign up for
free skip a month or cancel at any time
baby each box is valued at seventy
dollars and ninety percent of everything
that comes in your box of awesome is
from a small up and coming brand like
the big man said get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage to
check out that's box of awesome.com go
garbage for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code garbage do it man well
you didn't uh we were flying where [__]
where were we just flying to might have
been to Tampa we were flying to Tamp
member I don't want to not to make fun
of but it was a larger gentleman
remember the guy next to us oh man dude
we were sitting in a poor back sitting
in the front row so the it's the tray
doesn't come down it comes up out of the
side you know what I mean yeah and he's
a big gentleman yeah yeah you know and
I'm you know I'm no spring chicken
myself newer is my cool cohort here so
we're not [__] on them but dude
they're like what are you gonna they
come up they're like do you want first
of all it's a 90 minute flight they had
a chick they had a they had a grilled
chicken salad grilled chicken there was
a grilled chicken salad some sort of
Veggie type thing no they had a they had
a uh an impossible burrito possible
burrito yeah
I tried to Elbow you and a burger and he
goes all right like a pub burger and a
burger no no so I'm going and my ears oh
I'm talking to the fat guy next to me so
I'm like first of all like he shouldn't
even be eaten you know what I mean
reeled in a little bit because dude then
they came and brought him the tray he
got the last Burger I was Furious I
jammed up with a [__] impossible
burritos all right though he comes over
dude and the [__] the tray don't come
out over his stomach so he's got
he's resting the tray dude and he's
[__] elbowing me I'm like God damn I
can't make I didn't eat for the rest of
the day it was bad dude it shook him to
the core dude man yeah because he's got
the extender too right oh yeah so he's
got the extender and then the thing
doesn't come out to you so he's eating a
burger just like holding the tray it was
I was like dude this is this is this is
holding a tray under his neck I felt bad
like he was getting his communion
I felt terrible it was it was a bad look
the ghost of lunch is future yeah yeah I
was literally about to be like you know
what I'll have that I'm fine literally
damn I was gonna tell him he'll turn
your light off
[Applause]
buddy it's 90 minutes dude you'll be
fine just get something at the airport
when you lame
some hot chick came up behind him can
you eat that in the bathroom
[__] poor bastard
[Music]
he was fatter than me right I always ask
first question come on come on he was
bigger than me do you see that guy I was
in the bag
he was in the uh
I think you were built different I dude
come on his leg was bigger that is the
funniest [__] response it's different
bone structure I should be running for
congress with that answer
you're like lineman fat I couldn't tell
he had sunglasses
I couldn't tell the headphones were
blocking my view I couldn't get a good
look at the guy man dude I feel bad for
the person sitting next to that it was
his wife's wife oh who also yeah she was
she was a [__] uh Smash Burger Jesus
they should have put them on either side
of the plane
I'm gonna [__] balance it out
first of all the road was her and me
Listen sweetheart we're gonna get some
rough air we need you to bounce back was
up
we were doing an end though all the way
to [__] it I have a nose Wheeling we had
about I've seen a paper airplane do that
we had about 1500 pounds up there I mean
yeah I'm 230 235 you're whatever you're
telling people nowadays
you know you get fat when you just
started lying
do something do something I'm like two
and whatever you guys think I am
I seen a picture
what are you talking about 20 pounds
a burger
[Laughter]
I got the impossible burrito he sat
there so mad at me dude just won the eat
and he cut it I could just feel him
[__] I couldn't I couldn't but he he
he got it he got it I couldn't do it I
think if they would have came to me
first he might have done the fat guy
gentleman thing I've been like sorry
this is your time you have it I wasn't
going to do that Nick I couldn't I
couldn't I wish I went to my physical
and I was doing good I was just running
and everything and she goes like this
they go they go this is like last year I
like gained a little bit since but she
goes oh is it 186 and I got I can't be
right I heard the doctor left
now you're lying to me I couldn't I was
psyched I heard 186 I got happy and I go
no I think they didn't move it another
night
or whatever but it was it was right and
then I gained it bam but yeah 180 I've
been 186 since third grade yeah I was at
in high school dude really yeah dude it
scared me though when they go hey you
want to step on the scale I'm like no it
wasn't that much different from last
year just [__] ballpark just Dad just
act like we're on a boardwalking guess
my weight it's five every year playing
winter rules here doc what are you doing
come on can you just look at me
Ah that's all right well you had a good
time out there we had a good time we had
a good time it was nice being with my
wife and like sure not do comedy sure
comedy was done a life baby comedy was
done I was you know saw some friends up
there and you know Central California
wine country dude first time to Wine
Country are you first time first time
country at like a resort where it's like
it was great man are you pulling an
outfit out of the closet for that or did
you get something new for it how'd you
play this I had a new suit okay I had a
new suit so that Stacy brought uh but I
did one trash move where I had to run
out to TJ Maxx because I didn't have a
white button down
I didn't have a white button down so we
ran out to TJ Maxx that's all right you
know dude that's the dirt bag move yeah
I've done it every event I've ever gone
to TJ Maxx Marshall have saved more
marriages yeah but listen if you need a
nice crispy white you gotta you gotta
just find it some you know sure yeah and
you're like all right I'll spend
whatever it is 14.99 grab an arrow real
quick you'll be all right you want to
know if somebody's a real piece of [__]
look at that white collar at weddings
yeah blood stains yeah you guys got the
hair dude
it's like dude I got a couple man
I think you were in a sewer yeah
I went right up on you huh you ran in to
save that baby and he kept the [__]
you kept the white on
I was in a dressing room crying around
the whole place went up no no no I'm not
gross I'm a hero I fully got out before
the ceiling collapsed but then he had to
make the cocktail hour man I don't want
to miss this you two love birds lost a
lot of good guys in there I'll tell you
that right now sit all over his [__]
face it looks like a cartoon explosion
he smoldering doing the [__] Macarena
[Laughter]
I did that for my brother's uh my
brother not my brother's wedding that
what's the night before the uh person
that never heard the dresser yeah the
rehearsal dinner yeah I ran to a [__]
oh man I remember being so poor [__]
jammed up I had a jacket I was doing
like a nice pair of gray khaki not even
that I was still I thought they were not
doing a pair of gray khakis [__] uh
and then like a blue blazer and I was
just gonna grab like a white yeah like
whatever a white Oxford or whatever and
I I ran down to a polo store that was
the only thing available like brought in
Walnut it used to be right there [__]
I had to spend my last 88 bucks buying
this button up and I didn't realize it
was [__] short sleeved oh it was way
too late and I didn't have enough money
to go buy another one dude I just keep
my jacket on the whole day oh man
sweating that sucks I leaned into
somebody like yeah you want to see some
[__] stupid but they're like what I
just pulled my one sleeve off but as a
bigger guy if you're not taking your
jacket off that's way more comfortable
to have the short sleeves yeah you just
can't you look like [__] Dilbert at
the wedding
you look like you're an accountant yeah
you can't you can't rock the shorts
check out the first 48 over there huh
uh all right where's the perp at
oh my God you're drinking coffee in a
wedding
oh we were asking the guys that you mix
it up at the wedding when you get out
there on the Dance Floor no nothing no
like if my wife wants to do a slow down
if she wants to do a slow one I'll go
out there but I'm not doing [__] you
know okay I'm not you're sitting you're
sitting over there with the rest of the
uncles and stuff like that you know
we're talk yeah like I like to you know
what I do I talk to the older gentleman
like I was talking to like the older
uncles and like the guys in their 70s
nice shooting with them like I like
doing that stuff but if my wife is like
hey they're playing a nice song all the
couples go out sure I gotta you know
I'll do that you know I start doing a
chicken dance I'm not lying dancing you
know what I mean they're doing the work
the [__] limp human limbo where they
[__] put their already nuts
I'm not doing that [__] could you do the
worm back in the day though did you have
any moves when you were younger just a
running man
hahaha
you know the Running Man was my [__] The
Running Man picture version of the high
top fade used to pay to rent with that
thing yeah the Running Man was you know
it was a nice easy simple yeah you know
not too many moving Parts yeah you just
kicked the arms and the feet out it's
all good just the running man that's
[__] great yeah
um
okay would you smoke it do you smoke a
stick at the wedding multiple yeah
that's the thing you go you have like a
couple of good ideas whatever you pop
out that's when that's my favorite time
in any event is when you're like a pop
out the formals the formalness is done
everybody got the pictures yeah let's
all [__] undo the collar a little bit
post up on a nice porch or [__] patio
get a couple of stingers heaters going
Tommy Cassidy had that at his wedding it
was real nice he had the porch with the
cigars it was it was nice so but I
pulled a nice move where the one of the
wives I think bartnick's wife goes oh
all the all the boys are over there
smoking a cigar and I go and there's
like this crazy like cement gazebo and
everyone's just it's dark everyone's
just smoking and I was doing it for a
little I'm like I'm not gonna leave my
[__] so what I did I don't want to
leave my wife you know because she's
like there alone sure sure so I did like
five minutes put it down went over you
okay sat with her talked to her you know
it worked out she appreciated it there
you go you guys are gentleman you got
you know he's a classic ladies and
gentlemen the wife with strangers in
California
wear that as you get older and you know
it's especially when they don't have
yeah they got nobody they got no anchor
you know what I mean yeah there was a
couple of whack jobs there too yeah that
was a [__] girl with purple hair no
that was an old lady
no
no this old lady was like would you like
to go get me a glass of champagne and uh
honey I'm married
she said you know what she said she goes
I had four husbands they all died and
then somebody else's wife goes that's
suspicious but uh got blood on your
hands lady one of the guys was famous
I'll tell you like one of the but she
was old yeah one of her husband but she
would but she was one of those that was
like you know those people that they're
so I don't know if crazy but they'll
just go are you you're Kevin Ryan yeah
you do can you go get me a lobster and
you're just like what the f like it's
almost so crazy that if you can't say no
because yeah you're like I just want to
throw her a lobster and like never see
her again sure you know I was just
talking to somebody about this was it
with you I forget who it was of like
I've gotten real kind no wasn't you I
got real kind of not rude but like oh we
were golfing and someone came up and was
like like you're in the parking lot and
I was just like dude I don't I just
walked away and let my body talk to him
wait what did he want this guy just came
up was like oh how often do you hit them
random guy oh just a random dude you're
gonna talk to me in a parking lot I'm
like if it was a friend of my friend or
something I go hey man I'm for sure
gonna be polite in cordial and maybe
connect with you but I'm like buddy
you're just a lonely guy in a parking
lot in Jersey I'm leaving prickly in
your old age huh well what are we doing
here times the times of the essence
buddy yeah yeah I entertain it until I I
entertain it for like a little sure but
then when it's just like this is not you
know this guy is a little bit the worst
is when when that happens and then it
doesn't hurt a little argument but when
you disagree on something they come over
and they start talking to you like oh
you know they build this and that and
the other thing and then you're like
yeah yeah yeah like no no no that's not
what I I it's the like they disagree
with you yeah yes
it's like yeah it's like you're lucky
I'm even engaging in this [__] thing
now all of a sudden it's a debate yeah
no I know exactly what you mean you know
what I mean yes it's the worst one but I
got six million likes in me and [__]
shot a terrible game get away from me
I know I know man I had a dude come out
we were drinking somewhere and he asked
for my life later ask for a cig and then
my later I'm like yeah sure and then
he's holding this he's holding my
lighter hasn't looked to say and he's
like yeah I'm just having a real rough
year I'm like buddy this you ain't you
got the wrong guy to talk to call your
brother or something it ain't me wait
you're still smoking cigs now yeah what
are you doing I don't all right smoking
eaters what do you think he just turned
into my dad room what the [__] no I mean
yeah I know I'm trying to get off them
it's tough Paul I know I know it's tough
you're married though you got a nice
thing going on I'm trying I'm fat I'm
bald and I smoke cigs welcome to the
show oh I try to talk to him turn it
around yeah guy smokes more tonight he's
like yeah but I get the impossible
burrito The Impossible hey I'm not this
fat piece of [__] huh what are you
smoking what are you smoking marbies
more blights okay it's a nice Bernie you
know it's a gentleman will you ever have
a heater at like the wedding if you got
a couple in you no no never what
cigarette yeah no no it'll be a cigar
okay yeah uh back in the day I I did uh
marble lights they also did the
parliaments shout out to the people yeah
he ain't nothing wrong with him but then
when I was like you know couldn't walk
up a flight of stairs at 25 years old I
was like I just hopped up along laughing
at you
yeah sorry but no you're a good kid I
don't want anything to happen to you no
I'm trying that's it I'm awful but after
this show I'm done we're going away this
week I'm fine after we get back I'm done
you want to do an Indy 500 what quit see
I'll do that with you what you smoke
cigs too yeah he smokes them like a
chimney what are you [__] nuts yes
yeah yes he is it's bad news what do you
do what do you go pack a day no okay
you're not not a pen or am I I'm not
working at Nasa what do you mean a pack
a day you're not not smoking a pack a
day but that's the thing if I'm smoking
it's close to if when I was smoking it
was a close to a pack close maybe like
every two days if we're out if we're on
the road you're at a pack a day no
definitely not I'm not no way I've never
come back I'm telling you I never smoked
a pack a day in my life Toby can I get
away in on this maybe he might be you
might be at 17 but you're not not a pack
a day he's 18 going I told you he's
showing you the time I told you two of
them were wet
I mean also I'm gonna say dude if we're
if we're traveling that day we're
stopping every hour in the car you're
cranking heaters I'm cranking heaters
we're boozing we're cranking haters I'll
do that we're a heater crew what get
back get back from Indy quit smoking go
cold turkey all right listen I I just I
love you both I don't want anything to
happen but listen I know when it's nice
you know come on Six beers and Enlighten
us see good afternoon let's switch over
to Cigars yeah I'll be smoking a pack a
day she's smoking 20 cigars a day
for a [__] ride to Raleigh 15 Maduros
ah smoking 20 black a miles which are
the trashiest things man oh as a guy who
used to smoke them from time to time
yeah I thought you dude I thought I was
you guys will keep the bugs away
I thought I was Fidel Castro smoking him
when I was like 17. I'm like wow I
thought I was real wise that's so funny
today's episode is sponsored by better
help oh yeah gang it's easy to get
caught with what other people need but
the big question is what do you need
what are you doing to take care of
yourself better helps online therapy
gives you the time and the space to
focus on the most important thing which
is you that's exactly right you can't
help anybody else unless you help
yourself on an airplane to tell you okay
you got to take care of your mass before
you take care of the bozo next to you
even if that Bozo's your kid you gotta
take care of yourself very true uh I'm a
big proponent of uh talk therapy it's
been fantastic through me through
different points in my life I highly
recommend it it can only help you
[__] figure stuff out in worst case
scenario uh if you don't benefit from it
you can always pivot to find another
person or a different Specialist or
whatever that works for you there's no
sterile doctor's offices here everything
is Affordable flexible and completely
done online take care of your mental
health from the comfort of your own home
gosh darn it uh like I said if you need
to change therapists you can switch it
anytime and no extra charge give therapy
a try so you can keep supporting the
ones you love without leaving yourself
behind uh find more balance with better
help visit betterhelp.com garbage today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com garbage betterhelp.com garbage
now back to that gosh darn show back to
the show all right let's do some cues
here let's do some cues guys you know
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on here we
get a lot of submissions at the end of
the emails patreon gets first crack at
it because they're the homies you know
what I mean this one's a home run this
from Victor 10 homie from Maryland shout
out to you ever seen one of your parents
drink an energy drink
[Applause]
I don't even think they know what it is
like I don't even think they know that's
tough man dude if I saw my dick I'd lose
all respect for my mom if she started
drinking a white monster I feel like
listening I mean my dad thinks you're
low class if you have a beer seriously I
mean my dad is [__] yeah my dad's
wearing a [__] fur coat in August you
know so just to show you he's got it
yeah yeah my dad is going to get the
mail yeah my dad's not my dad would
never do seeing my dad with a monster
drink in his hand would be there's a
better chance of a UFO coming down to my
house today sure you know yeah no never
seen that that's a rough that's a bad
look man but I guess he hates those
things you got it I think it depends on
age because you know
you drink them sure so like if you had
kids
our parents are Generations like if
you're at least 20 now your parents
shouldn't be drinking energy drinks sure
but there's a lot of parents drinking
energy drinks yeah I'm trying to get
through today yeah I don't ever that's
dude that's like soda to me that's like
drinking soda breakfast people have
those in the morning instead of coffee
crack a Monster yeah and it's really bad
for you with the sugar and all that [__]
it's so [__] horrible they hit
different sometimes though they're all
right I do like a sugar-free Red Bull
sometimes I mean dude they [__]
sugar-free vegetables like the one thing
you know I said no writer the only thing
I say is I want one of these in a
sugar-free rib sure especially over for
you about to go out on stage if it you
know it's later in the evening the call
you're not really feeling a hot cup of
coffee half a sugar-free rabbit who's
bringing a hot cup of coffee on stage
you're over there boys
what's his name [__]
who's bringing a hot coffee excuse me
can I get a Splenda there's no creamers
on the stool you put another fresh pot
on this decaf yeah that's all right yeah
you're a psychopath to drink a hot
beverage on stage nah me and T-Bone like
a sugar-free Red Bull dude if I saw a
guy dipping a tea bag on stage
yeah listen just make sure there's honey
on the [__] stool I think what Taco
Bell is
now never uh no well my mom will do is
she'll do a like a Coke if she has a
headache that's like the cure-all that's
like the show that's a sugar thing I
think in the morning no no
yeah it's fine I mean it's trash but I
don't mind a bacon egg and cheese with a
Diet Coke not at all a Diet Coke for me
goes with anything yeah that's why I
like Diet Coke is dude Michael we go to
a diner on the road I get a [__]
water a large coffee black and a Diet
Coke I get three drinks dropped right
away and then I negotiate what as the
meal happens I love that and I think a
Diet Coke is just a universe yeah Diet
Coke has got no there's no hate for Diet
Coke no it is what it is it's good with
anything breakfast a cigar they can
straighten the end every once in a while
too yeah your Hungry Die Coke get thick
got a headache Diet Coke I mean it does
cause yeah I feel it did I feel it no my
my mother's cancer doctor said don't
drink diet I know yeah
or whatever they make it with hazmat
suits on I'm not joking yeah
got two beakers and smoldering
everything does oh [__] keep telling
yourself yeah everything does you had a
pack of cigs they're [__] nine Red
Bulls they're Diet Cokes they're a pain
in the ass about everything these days
aren't healthy I don't know what to do
oh my God uh uh all right this one's
from Lieutenant lollipop uh ever gotten
athlete's foot someplace other than your
feet
I had bad jockets for years where I had
it when I was a kid what do you mean
that's an athlete's foot it might be the
same thing I think it is I had jock itch
when I was like from like 10 to 14. what
constantly taking a shower yeah what did
you do you sprayed that you sprayed it
it's an acting on there
over here
I wonder why you weren't using the wrong
medicine in wrong parts of his body it
smelled like a goddamn engine block no
girls going down there
Robitussin down there it's a wrong
[__] mess whatever it is jacket spray
okay what's it called Toby uh I think
you're Googling it all right I'm
Googling the disease not the Cure okay
they are the same thing okay yes it's
the same does it's the same thing Tania
I tell you what though it sounds like a
stripper
shout out to dinner this is going to
sound like a real old man thing but
these days and it happens every once in
a while I'll get like a little tiny mild
case of athlete's foot and my on my
pinky toe on my right foot I don't mind
it it's real good scratching
dude I'm telling you sound like a dog
dude you take your sh you take your sock
off and start rubbing that on the carpet
it is
it's all right man I'm telling a little
bit athlete's foot I haven't done I
haven't had it in a while I had it as a
kid I remember being like what the [__]
yeah I thought my foot was falling off
yeah that's it I don't know what to even
say to that I want him or do you ever
have athletes put out like I've had
athlete's foot when I was like younger
yeah yeah you know and then yeah it
would go away you'd spray it on that's
when it like like gets like flaky right
yeah yeah but I haven't had it but what
do you mean you like the scratch yeah I
like I like the little itch of it he's
always a twisted guy yeah you know for
me it's gonna be the last time Mr verse
he does his show he's like you know what
I could go for I could go for a little
poison ivy every once in a while she'll
take the edge off I got it off this week
I like a little shoulder poison ivy just
it's a nice little scratch what do you
got in the sumac huh straight me out do
you have is your does your uh out of the
shower routine involve anything other
than deodorant use any talcum powder or
anything like that no no nothing I used
to there used to be a sponsor of the
version Effect called chassis and it was
for your down there it was anti-chafing
it seemed it was just like yeah there
was like also like even like cologne for
your balls stuff like that sure but then
I was just like uh I just stopped I love
like chemicals yeah no but I just go
that powder got real bad right that
talcum powder it came out that that's
like yeah people used to put uh Johnson
and Johnson baby powder on there and it
was like it's like horrible for you dude
I was doing it crazy I was doing it as
like a fat 12 year old dude it turned
into a cake down there yeah you just
dump your nuts in a [__] of course a
pile of flour some cornstarch I thought
it was I thought it was uh talcum powder
not baby powder baby powder is no good
oh no like they said that but
baby powder like the chemicals and stuff
back in the day might have changed it or
something but yeah it ain't great all
the time when I was a kid I think they
have put it under my arms like a [__]
what if somebody has accomplished
prostitute somebody's got something
that's like now you can do that but it's
safer like without chemicals or
something like that okay yeah just
Google like you know what do you do you
have a big routine when you get out I
don't have a big routine but I you know
there's a little spraying going on a
little this little that yeah a little
something crazy yeah just curious I
don't know what you did if you did a
little cologne a little bit of this
maybe an under eye cream I'm not sure
but you know what sometimes sometimes a
little lotion on the face and head okay
you know because I do lotion every day
I'm a dry Irish guy a little lotion on
the face sometimes but yeah it's usually
just but I like a good dry
a good dry you like being dry dry before
you put the clothes but I mean like you
can't here's the thing you can't put on
your boxer briefs and your socks even
damp you can't you know what I do you
got to go dry I don't mind I gotta go to
it and you gotta go two towels
are you doing a once over in the shower
when when you turn the water off so what
I do is I got them hanging right next to
your thing turn the water off one comes
out dry the head sir head and neck and
shoulders thoroughly inside the shower
yeah then I step out and I do the one
over okay and that's like then you're
good like 80 then you take the second
towel that's why Hotel towel is a great
because they're the dryer you don't have
to stand there a little bit my wife used
to get like these like nice towels but
it would just Glide over my face you
gotta have a little grit tone yeah yeah
they gotta have grits yeah I would have
like pink flakes all over my [__]
thread all over here yeah no but the
second one is what the real dry and a
good dry there's no smell there's no you
don't you won't smell
drying is everything will you do the
second try also in the bathroom I gotta
leave the bathroom because it's too hot
the fresh air hits you I gotta I gotta
get in front of the window unit I'll
walk around the master bedroom with the
second yes
I was gonna say you're probably gonna
judge me and this even wasn't no no
being this big yeah I've been doing this
almost my whole life I don't do it all
the time but I'll get the hair dryer
I'll I'll do I'll do all that I'll dry
off I'll go out hair dryer in the nuts
hair dryer down there fresh and
everything keep get it get it that's
gonna [__] your boys up dude it can't be
that warm no I just got to go far away
yeah just to get that off you can't you
can't you know you ever do this one you
ever [__] clip your toenail listen to
this you ever heard of this you ever
clip you you ever clip your listen to me
do you want to [__] change I love it
when Paul tells Secrets public yeah yeah
I know
everybody I literally looked around
everybody turn out I'm telling police
you have a clip your toilet no you ever
clip your tone on this and then put on
fresh socks from the pack oh yeah I'm
talking I'm talking I'm not touching a
hanger at all I'm talking the the you
get the fresh pack of socks rip them
open take one I'm talking fresh like
like bread out of the oven right with
the toenails just clipped and you put oh
it's it's it changes your day it'll
change your day you will get the cushy
and not the cheap socks because I got
the hands from CVS once it was a
disaster oh forget it those come with
holes in them they're like pantyhose
yeah brutal I think I have dress socks
on right now actually that's all I had
left listen I don't mind a pair of
direct socks with a pair of sneakers
every once I know but the sweats it's
all right don't hold up no a pair if
it's nice I'm walking in flippers it's
nice when they're not as they're easier
to put the shoes on yeah yeah it feels
nice yeah but dude clip your toenails
nice and like not not over short but
like really nice okay and then throw
right out of the pack socks on and then
socks and then the real kicker and this
happens to me a lot because I'm nuts
with it is if you can get a brand new
pair of kicks with the socks so now
you've got the toenails clipped a fresh
pair of socks and then you slide into a
brand new pair of take over the world I
mean dude you're floating 2024 baby yeah
it's like a Lexus ES 350 on your on both
feet
get the air freshener down there
what kind of air freshener you banging
with an Alexis right now what do you got
no no freshness no no he doesn't use it
I gotta um I spent a couple thousand for
the uh the detail yes yes and they redo
the air so they redo the air so the car
comes back brand new every time you get
seven a year a couple close Couple Grand
and uh but I take it to the wash every
two weeks in the inside and out so every
two weeks every two weeks I've only got
7 300 miles on this puppy that's all you
got yeah oh you got the new car yeah
yeah yeah white leather the whole deal
you guys got to take a tickle for a spin
work
what are you doing I got it downstairs
I'll take you guys for a couple laps
before we get to do the next one go
ahead change your radio you can do that
boys I'm downstairs get the cameras roll
get ready we're gonna go for a spin Paul
how many standing appointments would you
say you have in your life you're doing a
car every two weeks I imagine you got
the haircut lined up beer do you do they
do that no I don't I do like all the
stuff with my my shaving and grew up and
or grooming my is me okay that's that's
me car car is like we got a couple of
new car washes so I like to see what's I
like to see which one is poke around but
yeah but I I really want my car to be
Tip-Top shape do you like getting out
are you like being in it when you go
through no do you do the both okay so
you go in it first and then they come
out you get out and then they open all
four doors and a team of them just go to
work whoa yeah dude that's all right
it's [__] edited they get the fun
experience of going through it and then
you get the inside done yeah not bad and
I love watching the glossy Tire oh you
know the thing when they do that around
the tire that's great dude I say this
all the time one of my favorite jobs I
ever had is I worked at a car wash one
summer and it was just man because it's
like one of those things where you see
the work get you feel like you're
accomplished you're visually
accomplishing somebody pulls up in a
nice new car it's a little bit dirty it
goes through you do the wheels you
vacuum it out satisfying isn't it oh
it's nice it's satisfying Car Wash is a
good one they're very clean yes
everything's very clean not the one I go
to
you get that you get that Armor All in
your sneakers you're [__] slipping
around like they're on goddamn ice
skates dude I'm telling you if you get
caught in the pathway when it comes out
of the thing like you go back inside to
grab some pretzels it's like you're on
Wheels snap your neck
dude it's crazy how's your uh how are
you guys what's your teeth situation you
guys good with the teeth bad yellow
smoking I just spent I just spent like
10 grand I got I'm getting a couple
I'm getting getting veneers no no I got
I had an infection and this one had to
get pulled out and and then years ago I
lost this one so now I'm getting getting
them yeah that's good I'm missing a
couple getting two put in I had a bridge
done and uh you got to get a good
dentist man sure yeah I do
the smoking the coffee all that stuff it
jams them up a little bit but I'm really
I've lost twice a day like I do
everything you're not supposed I do
textbook what not to do but I floss
twice a day I brush all the time you
know what they say is horrible for it
what diet coke sure diet soda
a dentist told me once he goes you want
to not give us money anymore he goes
floss if you floss dude if the only
thing I do good in my life the gums are
strong around the but dude I had a
dentist [__] dude I had a dentist
talking to they can be [__] about it
now that he [__] poked he [__]
poked me in the eye with the [__] she
was like scraping around talking to the
girl that helped somebody [__] hit my
head go I'm like yeah dude I'm giving
you 10 grand here can we [__] tighten
it up my lip and [__] like yeah it was
uh but 10 grand to have a nice full set
of chompers and then I'm going
Invisalign dude okay here I'm going
Invisalign and then I'm going whitening
I gotta go I gotta whiten up dude I'm
bad my wifey was like you gotta wipe
I've been using the purple
[Laughter]
the purple stuff works good does it it
really is that's not [__] no it
works pretty good so the purple and you
could buy where can I get that I could
get that at like any any uh I use uh I
gotta get it online I use high smile I
think is the name of it okay I just fit
a bunch of research on this stuff as a
total scam it doesn't do [__] yeah they
stat and I didn't want to put her burst
your bubble I heard the same thing the
purple stuff doesn't work or the
charcoal don't work nah I'm telling you
that stuff works right when you do it
it's in your head man I don't know I
think it's it's a it's just a contrast
it's a natural contrast thing it's
yellow and purple make clear
tell me Kim Kardashian's lying yellow
and purple make clear yeah
I swear to god it works uh nothing on
that Toby
I don't know and maybe you have the one
that works I don't know I just heard
that they are all like really they're
like as seen on TV I don't know I damn
it I do use the Arm and Hammer [__]
whitening with peroxide or whatever the
[__] that thing I mean if you really
want to get them white used peroxide you
can't go back to regular [__] Crest
afterwards no no it's like a high level
[__] high level clean if you want to
do it right still yellow when he's bad
boys off if you want to do it right you
do peroxide but then your teeth hurt
like hell that's funny I use the
Sensodyne you're just still yellow after
that I'm gonna do a study on you I'm
Universe dude somebody get Procter and
Gamble on the phone we gotta clean me up
uh this says that he's putting primer on
his teeth uh this says that it's just a
rebranded China Chinese version that
AliExpress has been selling for like
eight and a half years
son of a [__] [__] Tommy bastards
got you I'm telling you I look in the
mirror it's white it's all marketing
yeah because it was just purple so
you're gonna look it ain't purple no
more it's white they saw you coming a
mile away yeah you know what they did
Kim Kardashian they threw Kim Kardashian
a few million to say it works sure and
you believe that
looking Broad
she could say cigarettes are good you'd
be like look yeah
she knows what she's doing she's gonna
lie to me
uh all right let's see here let's do two
three more
um
let's see all right one sec I [__] up
uh all right this is from Nick brand new
ten dollar uh homie never had one red is
a garbage to have to venmo your lawyer
you're losing that case pal I hate to
break it to you you're
you're serving some time in a clink dude
if he's taking cash apps
if this fucker's thinking cash apps so
what do you have on PayPal half on venmo
he's like listen pal I'm trying to get
you off a double murder don't put down
with his full reader I don't I just put
down pizza yeah just put the put the
pizza Emoji put down lunch or something
I don't make it look like they're paying
me back
I'm curious how Paul verzi feels about
yeah the public venmo transaction are
you a venmo guy I can't I love venmo
like but I don't like the public
you know you can click and make it
private I didn't know that yeah oh wait
I didn't know this
no I did know that yeah just because I
didn't want people seeing so I actually
did do that dude I got people I haven't
talked to in 15 years and I'm looking at
the transactions so and so since so and
so for money for game night or whatever
put your [__] on [__] private yeah
it's crazy dude I've seen couples doing
it and it's like yeah figure that out
offline the worst analog problem the
worst is when it's like pizza night
you're like what the [__] oh you ain't
got the 18 bucks put a couple slices on
the arm for that lady will you Jesus
Christ yeah that's nuts to me yeah no I
I don't mind the the cash apps for
things especially because nobody carries
cash on it is convenient so but I I like
the Privacy and the other thing I do is
like if you if somebody's got to go fund
me she's like hey man this kid fell on
hard times he said he was his kids sick
he's you know you you don't put the name
you don't put your name
[Music]
you guys are like those [__] people
that gave pizzas during the pandemic to
an emergency room and took a picture
with nurses and ate pies [__] you [__]
you you [__] you attention
I know your patreon's doing good let's
not get carry the [__] away here dude
you [__] Jesus oh man all right and I
think about it do it I should go I do go
I'll do it I just did it a week ago so
you kept the name I put my name but you
put it you put a lot right I put a lot
yeah I'm not doing it for 12 bucks I'm
showing oh then you're going out of it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
go hiding if it's under 250 he shows
somebody you believe this piece of [__]
look at me [__] it was for it
was for a comic thing like a and uh I
looked to see who else had given and
where I fell okay and you know yeah I
had to flex a little bit you know yeah
yeah so for a good cause that is true if
you go like a bow you're like yeah dude
there's a line so it's like over 250 you
show but then if you get to like
five grand not that I have but you're
giving away five grand then it's
Anonymous again it's classy to go
Anonymous yes you can't be like here's a
hundred grand from Kevin Ryan but also
sometimes with the comic ones you run
into an impossible so what you're saying
is you catch like schultzie or somebody
like that dropping two G's you're like
I'm putting 50 bucks and pulling them
out of it Anonymous yeah there you go
just so you so there's uh so so what
we've discussed is I say there's a
little buffer there's a little so if
it's if it's low and you know you could
but you can't go you go thousands you
look like a jerk sure you go too low you
look like a jerk so that that sweet spot
of generous and still enough to to let
you know that I'm classy yeah but I I
think it's real classy you know it's
real classy going going like what would
you say like three two grand Anonymous
that's wild yeah I don't I mean you know
words don't like it out
that's what you're hoping for you're
enduring group messages hey do you see
someone gave two grand that's crazy
was that too Grand you like maybe it was
I was too we were just talking about on
a patreon episode we went to my my
niece's play my brother donut was like a
gold level member or something and they
right off there like we like to thank
our Platinum our Diamond donators
our [__] we'd like to our our
titanium our platinums and then they
stopped at Golden they didn't read his
name he was so [__] pissed I'm like
what you doing it was 250. I go next
year you should be the Kevin Ryan
[__] theater
I turned into version real quick
Cocker's gonna be my theater oh no it'll
be good cheers the bar you guys buy yeah
shout out to goodies we'll have a
performance space upstairs you guys have
to have 100 seaters somewhere in the
back we're gonna do it upstairs like an
88-seater uh we used to do this thing
for my for my aunt years ago they had
like a silent auction man I lied my ass
off about putting it I can't believe I
didn't win I can't believe I didn't win
that trip to Aruba
you were a [__] 22 year old drug
addict
I can't believe I didn't get that
pontoon boat just holding up a random
piece of paper like oh [__]
dude venmo and your lawyers were off
that's bad oh so you gotta have a deal
with them up front be like listen here's
a what do they call it the the retainer
you have here's your retainer and then
we'll work something out we're not venmo
dude that's bad it's got to be private
it's also yeah it's real bad what you do
is somebody say I say you know we're
doing whatever a game that I I owe you
100 bucks I owe you 100 bucks will you
do the instant transfer or will you do
like to and pay the the fee because
there's a fee to get it instantly or
will you do like the two to three day
free no no no no no no never what I go
instant yes
two to three days
you know what could happen in two to
three days yeah
you're like the only person everybody I
mean we do I mean we're dirt bags we're
it's my money and it's JG Wentworth
but you wet your beak I'm okay with it
yeah yeah yeah give me I'll take 98
bucks I don't care yeah now give it to
me now
everybody says no they wait every single
comment comes in and says no they wait
they wait that's a nuts to me yeah those
are the people that don't get ATM money
you know the three dollars that was
that's the most I can't believe that
that's actually something I can't
believe people that can't people that
think the three dollars for the ATM is I
don't know no venmo I don't trust them
as a dirt ball when I'm jammed if I'm
taking money and taking money to the ATM
I don't give a [__] you could take half
yeah 100 give me my true take 20 I need
20 now when I'm drunk and gambling in a
casino you could [__] you could go
into my savings account
I'll give you more points on interest
and I gotta hit the [__] blackjack
table now yeah but if I if I win big
I'll give you a half just give me
I did that Dirtbag [__] with one time
where I was hammering all the bad
decisions are hammered in casino but you
know you could go with your credit card
I don't even know how that works dude I
don't think I ever said or something I
don't know here's how it works
you get hammered on interest so yeah
dude you're getting 100 bucks it's
costing like 215. so like we're gonna
tell you guys living in the guest house
better off getting money off the street
man ah but we gotta wrap it up gang what
a fun time oh dude love you buddy Mr
versie on tour right now you got the
three pods cooking yeah I got the three
pods cooking and I just gonna be out in
like two days plug uh this weekend
if I can plug I'll plug June
I have uh May 31st I'm doing a
one-nighter in helium Indianapolis
June one hilarities one night Cleveland
Cleveland's been asking when I'm coming
out there come out there nice get your
tickets I'm doing the penita theater in
northern Idaho I'll be in Sandpoint
Idaho I'm doing the penita theater guys
I don't even know what to expect it's
like right near Montana people are like
why don't you do it I'm like all right
yeah that's great so yeah if you're up
there come out there I'll be in Side
Splitters
um I'm gonna be at Side Splitters I
think the 17th and uh 17th and 19th or
I'll be a Side Splitters in the middle
of the in the middle of the month and
then um what else do I have I'm gonna be
in Houston on the 28th of June and I
will be in Addison on the 29th of June
All Dates at paulversey.com guys I'm not
joking is the best hour I've ever done
it's the best hour I've ever done I
promise you guys come out man I'll I
will uh you will not leave disappointed
Paul is one of the best gang you got to
go see him do stand up it's absolutely
amazing internal admissions on Netflix
yeah go check out The Necklace Netflix
special as well and bone to pick with me
and Bobby Kelly's brand new we're having
a lot of fun everybody that said Bobby
and Paul why don't you guys you guys
always bicker at each other you always
have her phone to pick why don't you do
it we've done like five episodes it's
going great me and Burr still do
anything better and the version effect
is now in studio so check all that out
guys dude you guys do you guys are my
favorites I couldn't be happier and uh
this is the this is if anybody says what
show you got to do it's this one we love
you so much what do you got for him uh
guys like we said we're all over the
road uh we're gonna be also at Cleveland
Columbus uh we have tickets we second
show in Red Bank New Jersey first row
sold out in a couple days second show is
gonna sell out as well get those tickets
let's party gang gang we love you and
we'll see you next week peace